the family you mentioned were all sat at
the back of the court before 24 year old
cody ackland was brought into the dock a
number of those family members were in
tears
today the judge had requested an
atmosphere of restrained silence
before ackland was brought into uh the
doc obviously an incredibly tense
atmosphere inside
the 24 year old pleaded guilty to the
charge of murdering 18 year old bombi
bobby ann mccloud she went missing
back in november last year she was on
her way to meet friends on a saturday
night and went missing on her way to a
bus stop a search then
began for a number of days and the 18
year old's body was found around six or
seven
miles south of plymouth near a beach in
bovisand
in woodland forensic teams spent a
number of days there and it was
a week or so actually before police
confirmed the identity
of uh the remains um
cody acklin was
part of an indie band as you mentioned
uh called recuda it disbanded upon the
news but it was a very popular band here
in plymouth he was the main songwriter
and guitarist as part of that band
and today here in plymouth he has
pleaded guilty in front of not only
bobby anne's family but also a large
number of supporters in fact the court
had to open up a second courtroom in a
video link for the large number of
supporters who were wearing justice for
bobby anne at t-shirts outside court
here they were here back at the hearing
in january as well um
this of course um will bring closure a
park closure for some of the family but
an inquest will now resume we don't
exactly have the details of to
the circumstances of what happened to
bobby anne back in november last year
but it certainly was a shock for the
city here there was a
candlelit visual towards the end of last
year in which hundreds of people turned
out i was there at that visual where
people
spoke and paid tribute to bobby anne and
laid flowers at the bus stop where she
went missing
and it was a part of plymouth which is
still reeling from the shock of of what
happened the
judge said that cody ackland will be uh
given a whole life sentence as of course
is mandatory with murder
the determination on the minimum term of
how long he'll serve in prison will be
made when he returns to court here in
plymouth on the 19th of may
okay dan thanks very much